[Music]
[Applause]
Chris fer knows his football segue Chris
just called the uh game between
Washington and Oregon State rivalry week
he's calling Florida State and Florida 7
Eastern on the Mother Ship also 30 years
of college game day on the road Chris
joining us now what was it like 30 years
ago do I get five guesses from
everything you asked me I just want to
make we had if you want to what was the
first road trip 1993 uh number one
versus number two at Notre Dame Florida
State uh Bowen versus Holtz it was an
epic kind of regular season game we had
been waiting for we had been lobbying to
get the show on the road for a while in
the regular season nobody really wanted
to spend the money that match up kind of
Justified it and uh it was it was pretty
cool we we didn't know what we were
doing out there in South Ben but we
stumbled on it and we got through it and
it was the birth but what when did you
know it was something it more than just
hey we're taking Sports Center on the
road or you know NFL prime time when did
it become like
uhoh we had done it in bowl games but
that wasn't the same thing as doing on a
campus so once we felt the energy the
pep rally at Notre Dame Friday night is
pretty wild uh you know of course so
said he wanted to change his pick after
watching the energy of Notre Dame's
campus on Friday night but ended up
going with the alma mater uh incorrectly
in that case but no Dan is in 94 95 we
took it on the road uh more regularly
and these crowds began to build he that
first day it's in the lobby of the Hall
of Fame people had wandered in Saturday
to let's check out some trophies where's
the Rockne display what what the hell's
going on over here is this a TV show
they really stumbled in like not knowing
what they were seeing uh game they
didn't have a very high profile back
then and but still you could tell once
the game was over over and they all
spilled back in there to celebrate Holtz
storms out of his office and up on the
set and just arrives unannounced and
sits down and takes a Victory lap I mean
we knew at that point to to be there on
a campus for these big games uh was
going to be something we also knew we
had a lot to learn how to Stage it all
right let me dive into college football
this weekend actually let's fast forward
to tomorrow night how does the committee
look at Florida State now with you know
Florida State losing their quarterback
uh how do you how do you kind of process
the resume and then forecast what you
think they're going to be they're
supposed to ignore what they think
Florida State's going to be with with
Tate rodmaker and others uh trying to
fill in for Travis because you can't
really replace him so they're going to
look at the resume the resume is good I
do think Florida State fans have a right
to be a little bit concerned um number
one because they don't have these big
wins down the stretch yeah okay it's a
rivalry game in Gainesville I'm going to
call that game on Saturday but the gator
have have staggered and and they're
they're just playing to get to six and
six and then Louisville a good team the
committee seems to like them but they
haven't really played a heavyweight
schedule themselves and then is beating
Louisville in the ACC Championship game
if it's close is that going to get them
over the hump if they're competing
against other teams with with great
resumés you'd like to think they would
not downgrade the current team based on
not having their quarterback uh they say
they don't but we'll see I go back to
what was it 2014 with Ohio State JT
Barrett and then Cardel Jones came in
and you know kept them in the playoffs
uh kept them relevant I don't know if
that'll be the situation here with
that's what you point to that's what you
point you if you're Mike norell that's
the best possible example and he
remember Cardell Jones was third
strength at the beginning of the season
because must be Braxton Miller's team
and he got hurt and Barrett takes over
and and that's the best example now I
don't know if if Tate rod is Cardell
Jones but I do know that the nolles have
some great pieces around him I mean J
Jamal Holloway remember he came in and
as a freshman replaced Troy Aman and
took him to the National Championship
running a totally different offense they
redid the offense for him and NFL you
know there's been many examples of
backups coming in and doing great things
and Brady on down the line that's a
different thing than college but you
know I think they've got enough to get
through the next two games and if they
get in the bracket you know I they
they'd have their hands full but uh
Travis was a special player I feel awful
he wasn't one of these guys that
transferred in Dan and was there for
like eight months five years at Florida
State five years through some really
really tough times and uh that was a
tough one for those of us that love the
sport and know him to watch him card it
off like that how interesting is
Michigan uh now what's happened are they
interesting off the field any
longer when a Harbaugh got there they've
been interesting man it was always
interesting to cover Michigan because it
was such such a unusual experience he
was just so quirky all the time that you
never sort of knew what you're were
going to get but um I mean yeah of
course it's super compelling I mean the
fact that they have pulverized Ohio
State the last couple of years um
completely manhandled them after
halftime I know they're going into that
game thinking the blueprint works right
we we beat him in a submission a couple
years ago and last year um 283 after
halftime they they think they're the
tougher more physical team you you know
that gets Ryan Day all fired up and
that's there's plenty of motivation on
their side but hey that's where that
came from that's where the thing came
from that Ohio State wasn't Tough Enough
at the line of scrimmage to beat these
big te was the the Michigan games the
last couple years so they they've got
the opportunity to to flip the script
but it won't be easy what about off the
field yeah I mean listen you people act
like Harbaugh's be sitting out because
they have to punish the program or at
least the Big 10 felt like they had to
answer answer to the 13 other teams and
L you some punishment um and they've
been making do without him but listen
you know the sign stealing thing is
fascinating I've had conversations with
coaches last few weeks about is it how
big a thing is it if you're an offensive
coach they think it's a huge thing
Lincoln Riley says there were double
digit points on Saturday if they have
your signals other defensive coaches say
well it depends on how much time you
have to react is it really that big an
edge I mean there's a difference of
opinion among coaches but what they're
United on is if you're going to record
it if you're going to take it to that
degree then you've gone way too far and
and when you break the rules
consistently um systematically and
effectively you're going to get punished
more than somebody else you can't say
hey well what about them no no you did
it way differently than they did
allegedly talking to Chris fer ABC
Saturday night football Washington and
Oregon State this uh past weekend he's
got Florida state Florida coming up this
week on a the mothership uh better team
not better resume better team Washington
Oregon Oregon I mean udub fans are going
to hate me saying that I I called the
game in Seattle um but I think that
Oregon has been has been consistently
dominant I mean it's very close to me I
mean I I think that Washington is still
really hard to beat because they got a
bunch of dudes are going to be playing
on Sunday who who who who pitch it and
catch it and and they know how to come
up with big plays when they need it but
but I think Oregon would be favored in
the rematch and I hope we get to see it
I would love to be there in Vegas for
that one with the playoff bit on the
line I mean it's a hatred game anyway uh
but I think they'd be favored probably
close to a touchdown they're that
impressive I think since the loss where
do you stand on the Heisman
race I mean I mean I I don't like to
talk about it because you got to be the
one standing there to interview the
winner never I never you're not going to
get my ballot out of me you're and you
never open the envelope right you never
know
what's they've got someone from the
Heisman trust I I know in the commercial
break before and I don't want to know
before that okay it's dumb to sit there
and like look at the finalists and I you
know make I you don't want to know until
the last second but I I do want to know
in the commercial break before in case
the the result goes some totally
unexpected Direction and I'm standing
there having to think of questions but
you know I I think that it's interesting
I mean you know Nicks has some very very
interesting stats and and Oregon has
obviously been a Powerhouse team I don't
know how you can be more impressive as a
quarterback than what Jaden Daniels has
done at LSU I don't know how you can
play better than that yeah I mean as a
thrower and a runner they've got three
losses they're not going to be playing
on Championship Saturday um he's got to
light up Texas A&M you got to take up
every chance you get but I mean to me
he's had an amazing season that's been
overlooked because or LSU just hasn't
been a playoff team yeah I I think
pennock's story is is pretty remarkable
with what he's done with Washington as
well and B Knicks with you know
transferring from Auburn and what he's
done as well yeah I'm kind of torn here
I mean Marvin Harrison Jr might be the
best player but I don't think you know
he's going to win the unless he did
something incredible against Michigan
well he's got to do that he he was the
best player on the field and it made a
difference in Ohio State's biggest game
well now this is a much bigger game can
he be the best player on the field and
make a difference you know we had three
catches last week they didn't need him
against and against a lot of opponents
if he weren't there the result is
totally the same not to Discount what
he's done he's been brilliant I think
romad dun of Washington what pennic his
major Target is is a Sure Fire NFL star
he's had a great season too fun Brock
Bowers might be the best player in the
country in any position if he's healthy
all year but again he's a tight end and
this is a quarterback Sport and I spend
50% of my time when I analyze a team
every week looking at the quarterback
analytics and every situational thing
you can think of because that's really
what decides games right how is the QB
on third down how is he in the Red Zone
it's come from Sunday down to Saturday
and you just have to acknowledge that
the sport is largely based on their
performance so why wouldn't the Heisman
go to the guy at that position 12 team
playoff next year any
downside um I think there's unintended
consequences and people who think that
this is a chance for all those who've
been overlooked and ignored to get in
you get you got an 18 team Big 10 you
got an expanded SEC with ou in Texas
where do you think the majority of those
playoff bids are going to go I mean
they're going to go to SEC 3 and four
big 10 three and four it's going to fill
the bracket up and people are going to
realize that no matter what you do
you're probably still going to have the
same heavyweight program standing at the
end it's going to be fun it's going to
be a lot of games down the stretch but
instead of determining whether they're
in the bracket it's going to be about
seating and home field that's what the
NFL is right so if you if you like that
model you'll like the college model if
if you think that college should be
distinct from the NFL um you're going to
be appalled at some of the changes
because regular season games Flatout
just won't mean as much they they just
won't you you know you think Alabama's
ever gonna miss the playoff Georg is not
going to be there State Michigan they're
gonna all be in there every single year
so um should Lincoln Riley be on the hot
seat no no but I I think they need there
needs to be some soul searching either
by him or or um the staff I mean they
they you have to you have to become
obsessed with defense if you're him
you've got to Simply address the fact
that defenses have not been good enough
and it's it's tough when you people see
a guy like Caleb Williams Come to USC
and he's gonna leave without winning a
conference Championship you it's like
Drake May probably the best quarterback
Carolina's ever had not going to win an
ACC Championship while he's there and
and you just hate to waste a
generational type talent because the
team isn't complete enough so you need
to make the team more complete you need
to you need to get much much better in
the trenches but I don't I don't put
them on the hot seat I mean they've got
they've tried through nil to get better
in the trenches I they didn't ignore it
but they just got a lot of work to do
before I let you go since we're
celebrating 30 years of college game day
whose idea was it for Coach Corso to put
on the headgear is I mean it it started
out with kind of a oh a baseball hat or
something lame and then was a helmet and
then then the Ohio State game where he
famously saw rudus Buckeye's head asked
for it they politely said no uh and then
they negotiated it because because K KB
Street's wife Allison was was part of
the cheerleading team that's that's a
true story and they finally convinced
them in the minute he put it on you talk
about a light bulb moment we didn't know
with the first road show but you knew
with the first headgear pick oh like
this is a thing and and you know this
many decades later it is part of Pop
culture but that that was the first one
and and uh I mean look Dan it's tough I
mean Lee Coro before he went through his
struggles with the stroke was you know
this what was a a dynamic electric
performer Ian he was nobody like him and
there never will be anybody like him
again he was so quick and so
instinctively funny and razor sharp in
in that kind of show business way and he
thought of it lightning struck that day
and and the rest his history but I I'm
sad that there's generations of viewers
that have seen you know Lee courageously
struggle with his situation I I it's
deeply moving to me it's powerful what
he's had to battle through but I I hope
people also go to YouTube and understand
that that for a couple decades that's
why game day in large part got to where
it was because of uh you know his
ability to sort of create and Spark and
be an Entertainer well put my best of
the family Happy Thanksgiving uh safe
safe travels there Budd whole crew there
we'll do it again thank you bud that's
uh Chris fer college game day